would the princess bride make a perfect
double feature with the mummy what do
robin williams and brendan frazier have
in common these are the adventure films
to watch if you love the mummy
fans looking to get their adventure fix
need look no further than dr henry
indiana jones as played by legendary
actor harrison ford he's been rocking
the whip and fedora combo for the last
30 years to date his tenure as the
archaeologist adventure has resulted in
four films with a fifth indiana jones
film in the works it all kicked off with
1981's raiders of the lost ark in which
indy searches for the fabled ark of the
covenant believed to contain the stone
tablets on which the ten commandments
were inscribed which is supposed to have
the power to make one's army
undefeatable who would be interested in
such an ability nazis that's who the
fascist german regime would appear again
as adversaries in 1989's third
installment to indiana jones and the
last crusade which included a quest for
the holy grail the second film 1984's
indiana jones and the temple of doom
served as a prequel to raiders and was
primarily set in india with dr jones
taking on a thuggy cult and its chief
priest mularam
indiana jones in the kingdom of the
crystal skull came out in 2008 and
swamps the soviet union and its kgb and
as indies antagonists it has the
distinction appearing in the worst with
reviewers though its 78 critics score
and certified fresh distinction on
rotten tomatoes simply reflect how
beloved the franchise is as a whole by
any name indiana jones is a classic i
like indiana we named the dog indiana
sahara is a fun 2005 action adventure
flick starring matthew mcconaughey as
late author clive kessler's prolific
adventurer dirk pitt adapted from the
novel of the same name in sahara pitts
is searching for some long lost treasure
the hall of gold that was loaded onto
the confederate ship css texas at the
end of the us civil war despite its
talented cast and intriguing plot sahara
was mostly panned by critics managing
just a meagre 38 critic score on rotten
tomatoes
viewers were a bit kinder to the film
though as evidenced by its 53 audience
score in addition to its lack of
critical success the film was beset by
numerous problems including a massive
160 million dollar budget that was
doubled from its original 80 million
dollars according to the los angeles
times sahara is believed to have lost
the studio 78 million dollars making it
among the biggest box office bombs of
all time but it's still a fun popcorn
movie for date night
looking for indiana jones but with a
little less swagger and a much bigger
brain meet noah wiley is flynn carson
the title character of the librarian
franchise think of the librarian as the
ultimate keeper of knowledge in addition
to being the protector of the actual
tree of knowledge over the course of
three films including 2006's the
librarian returned to king solomon's
minds and 2008's the librarian curse of
the judas chalice the totally bookish
and mostly meek hero tracks down the
spear of destiny searches for ancient
treasure and meets the girl of his
dreams while trying to protect the
vampire equivalent of the holy grail
that's in addition to inspiring the
spin-off tv series the librarians which
ran for four seasons on tnt
you can't compile a list of adventure
movies worth watching without including
the national treasure franchise the 2004
film and its 2007 sequel national
treasure book of secrets feature actor
and human meme nicholas cage as
historian and adventurer benjamin
franklin gates the first installment
sees him steal the declaration of
independence from the national archives
in washington dc but don't worry it's
totally for a good cause protecting it
from other thieves led by a former
friend and colleague all parties
concerned are in search of a storied
treasure trove from the founding fathers
and believe the declaration contains a
clue that'll put them closer to their
goals of finding it the sequel sees
gates setting about defending the honor
of his ancestor thomas gates who is
tasked with decrypting john wilkes boost
journal he did so and failed to stop the
assassination of abraham lincoln
ultimately dying at the hand of
confederate sympathizers though it's
been a decade and a half since the last
film fans have reason to be excited as
disney has announced both a third film
and a new tv series on disney plus
the mummy franchise was so successful it
spawned a spin-off film series tied to
the second movie the mummy returns sees
our hero trying to save his son who's
foolishly put on the bracelet of anubis
and will die if they don't get him to a
magical locale in a week's time there
rick o'connell does battle with the
equally mythical scorpion king who sold
his soul to anubis in ancient times in
the scorpion king movie dwayne the rock
johnson in his first lead role takes on
the part of the scorpion king though in
the days before he became the legendary
ruler instead he's a mercenary he's been
hired to kill a sorceress who's
conquering tribe after local tribe the
scorpion king spawned four direct to
video sequels in its own right though it
was one and done for johnson alas
[Music]
when it comes to jumanji nothing beats
the 90s original starring robin williams
the late great comedic actor took on the
role of the adult version of alan
parrish a young boy who gets sucked into
the game in the 1960s literally he's
trapped in the world of the titular
magic board game a couple of decades
later two kids discover the cursed board
game unwittingly releasing allen from
its confines and forcing them to finally
win the game or else in addition to the
sequel it would later receive jumanji
was spun off into a slightly more
technological direction with 2005's
athura space adventure jumanji welcome
to the jungle served as the first direct
sequel to the original film and saw the
game change media into a video game with
heavy hitters like dwayne johnson kevin
hart karen gillen and jack black as part
of the cast and they all reprise their
roles in 2019's jumanji the next level
just like the jumanji franchise viewers
have options when it comes to the
adventures of laura croft the 2001
action adventure film laura croft tomb
raider saw actor angelina jolie bring
the title character to life and all her
skin type glory her first outing is the
titular adventure and star of the tomb
raider video game franchise caesar up
against the illuminati joined by a pr
james bond daniel craig as they race to
assemble an object that allows a person
who wields it to control time jolie
reprised the role in 2003's lara croft
tomb raider the cradle of life with the
on-screen sparks this time flying
between her and still rising star gerard
butler as the two seek out pandora's box
jolie declined to take up the role a
third time and tomb raider rebooted the
franchise in 2018 with actor alicia
vikander taking up the mantle of laura
croft and what amounts to an origin
story the reboot failed to impress
critics managing a middling 52 percent
critics score on rotten tomatoes but
vikander received praise for her
performance and the movie did well
enough at the box office for a tomb
raider sequel to get the green light
stardust springs to life from the
brilliant mind of celebrated writer neil
gaiman the 2007 fantasy adventure rom
follows the exploits of tristan thorne a
bumbling but romantic young shopkeeper
who's so smitten with local beauty
victoria that he promises to journey to
retrieve a fallen star for her hand in
marriage and from there hijinks ensue
stardust proved popular with both
critics and audiences earning a
certified fresh rating of 77 from
critics and an even better 86 audience
score if you like your romance with a
side of magical adventure or vice versa
then stardust is a film for you
like stardust the league of
extraordinary gentlemen came from the
mind of a legendary graphic novel writer
in this case alan moore lxg as the film
was marketed adapts a graphic novel
series of the same name and unites a
handful of popular adventure characters
as the titular team legendary big game
hunter and adventurer alan quartermaine
played by sean connery is recruited out
of africa to lead a squad featuring the
likes of dorian gray whose immortality
is tied to a portrait that ages in his
stead mina harker whose vampirism is a
result of her husband jonathan's former
employment by count dracula the
invisible man rodney skinner a thief who
stole the secret to invisibility from
its creator nemo captain of the
submarine nautilus and maybe a pirate as
well american secret service agent tom
sawyer and dr jekyll and his abominable
counterpart mr hyde the ambitious
adventure film drew characters from the
works of mark twain oscar wilde jules
verne robert louis stevenson bram stoker
h.g wells and more just like its comic
book inspiration it fared well at the
box office grossing 179 million dollars
against a 78 million dollar budget
though critics weren't as kind to the
edgy steampunk romp as audiences as the
film earned just a 17 critics rating on
rotten tomatoes but hey if you like your
dump on extra dumb this should be right
up your alley
action adventure enforces beyond what
mere mortals can wreck and await viewers
in the pirates of the caribbean
franchise unquestionably the most
successful cinematic adaptation of a
theme park ride that has ever existed
the swashbuckling adventure series
follows the misadventures of captain
jack sparrow who is simply trying to get
his ship back in the first film in the
course of events his path crosses
without a pirate obsessed socialite
elizabeth swann and will turner the
blacksmith who's in love with her so
much so that'll break jack out of prison
if he agrees to help rescue her from her
pirate captors who just so happened to
be the mutinous crew that marooned jack
stealing his ship in the first place
it's like it was meant to be the 2003
film pirates of the caribbean the curse
of the black pearl spawned a trilogy
that included dead man's chest in 2006
and at world's end in 2007 stars johnny
depp and jeffrey rush both returned for
the 4th and 5th installments on stranger
tides in 2011 and dead men tell no tales
in 2017. together the films have grossed
more than 4.5 billion dollars worldwide
and a sixth pirates of the caribbean
movie will reboot the franchise without
depp at the wheel
you cheated
pirate adventure lovers who haven't seen
the cult classic the princess bride
would do well to resolve that issue as
quickly as possible it packs in plenty
of heart and wit in addition to danger
and excitement adapted from the novel of
the same name the princess bride follows
the travails of wesley a young stable
boy who serves princess buttercup
without question with the two eventually
falling in love wesley sets out to make
something of himself in order to be
worthy of buttercup's hand in marriage
but his way laid by the dread pirate
roberts well known for taking no
prisoners heartbroken buttercup is
engaged to prince humperdinck against
her will thankfully yes thankfully she
is kidnapped before her wedding by three
scallywags a thief named vizini a giant
named phezik and a swordsman named anigo
montoya who seeks to avenge his father's
death and spawn a million memes they're
pursued by prince humperdinck and his
soldiers in addition to a mysterious man
black the 1987 film is an enduring
favorite among movie lovers of multiple
generations while it didn't smash any
box office records it grossed 31 million
dollars globally against its 15 million
budget it was a modest financial success
but it's gone on to become a cult
classic so you want to watch the most
fun adventure movie of all time well
princess bride has just one answer to
that request
as you
wish
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]